[Music]
somewhere around 75,000 years ago don't
worry I'm not gonna go too long on this
but around 75,000 years ago human beings
who are anatomically and behaviorally
the same as us modern human beings a few
of them decided to Trek on out of Africa
and begin a 40,000 year project or so of
populating virtually the entire world
becoming a global species which we are
now perhaps the only global species with
I think the possible exception of
cockroaches I'm not positive for that
but I think that's correct and now we
find ourselves on the threshold of
becoming possibly a universal species or
at least entertaining ideas of
inhabiting places beyond this earth that
we live on so this new migration however
I have to say is is different not only
quantitatively from the original out of
Africa diaspora but qualitatively
because we're now talking about a
migration to a place that has never
influenced our evolution in any way and
so the question is will we be able like
the first migration to be able to do
this by the use of technology and
science without really changing our
biology or will we now have to resort to
changing our biology to making ourselves
in some way or another more adapted or
more adaptable to environments that are
even difficult to predict so let me
welcome our panel to begin with our
first participant is a geneticist and
associate professor at Weill Cornell
Medical Center please welcome
Christopher Mason
also with this is evening professor of
genetics at Harvard Medical School and
the director of the consortium for Space
genetics
please welcome ting wood our final guest
this evening is the director of
astrobiology at Columbia University
where he studies among other things the
condition on the conditions on other
planets that make them habitable for
life please welcome my friend and
colleague caleb sharp have a seat thank
you good I'm going to jump right into
this with question to Caleb who said in
his Scientific American blog that the
possibility of humans living on other
planets is quote terrifyingly hard to
think about and that's the best thing
about it what's hard and what's so good
about it
well I think some of these other people
on stage you're going to explain what's
hard about it and what happens when you
go to environments that are radically
different than the one we've evolved out
of but what's what's good about
conditions on another world or in space
being so horrific ly difficult from my
perspective and what I was getting at
when I wrote that article was the idea
that every time humans are challenged
with something radically new and
especially in exploration especially in
survival there's the opportunity for
good things to happen there's
opportunity for us as a species to
expand not not just physically across
new territories in our solar system but
as as a species our conception of what
it means to be human
alters and our conception of the
preciousness of of the origins that we
have here on earth
I think expands and improves so that was
really what I was getting at that this
idea of lots of motivations for our
species to spread itself into the cosmos
I mean their motivations that are quite
simple to do with potentially having a
back-up plan living living on a planet
is an inherently treacherous thing
especially on longer timescales and most
of us experience in our lifetimes
so having a sort of offworld storage
system and offworld backup plan is not a
bad idea and of course the scientific
enterprise exploring the universe around
us humans are pretty good at that I mean
we build wonderful robots to explore the
universe around us and that gets us a
long long way but many reasons to
believe that putting a human in an alien
environment is the most efficient single
most efficient way of learning about new
places and I think the Apollo astronauts
an example of this when you put a
geologist on the moon they did more in a
couple of hours then you could do with a
rover in in years and years and years
Chris you think a lot about the future
and long-term futures which I which I
find very intriguing because I think a
lot of our science tends to be you think
of scientific experiments that you hope
you'll see the results of in your
lifetime so that puts a sort of a narrow
vision and one of the wonderful things
about science for me is this kind of
wider bigger frontier so you're making
plans out for 500 years isn't is that
what you're thinking about we're on year
five of about a 500 year lab plan I will
be not funded that for all of it I will
of course be dead for the vast majority
of it but I think it's actually really
one of my favorite things
well first it's terrifying for people
who want to come in the lab they think
they're gonna be there for 500 years so
that in the sense to have the experiment
necessarily go that long but actually to
you know to think about a multi-stage
plan to learn as much as we can about
the human genome and other sort of the
ecosystem that we all are represented by
as well as ways to to find sort of I
like to call do not disturb lists and
places that we can alter to some degree
in the human genome and the other
genomes we have because I think we will
have to have this list as sort of a
parts list of the human genome as some
people call or they're the areas that
you can tweak because we will probably
need to do it for some of the places
that we'll go Mars is not a hospitable
place and so a lot of the plan is to
learn as much as we can in a functional
capacity and then near 20 30 years and
then begin some of the engineering and
long-term
sort of tests on of people on other
planets and I I think it's a very
quintessential human trait is that we
all have an innate capacity to actually
plan beyond our own lifetime which as
far as we know is unique to our species
and so I think it's our it's your duty
as a human being to at least have one
plan that's beyond your lifetime and the
simplest example is just children we'll
have children it's obviously beyond
Arlington
students so so one of the places that
that I think actually makes a job of
planning that is the is the Consortium
for space genetics which you direct
thing could you tell us what you do at
the consortium for space genetics yes
and perhaps the best way to do that a
little bit of history how we came
together so most of us started in the
department of genetics without a focus
on space but of course many of us were
inspired by space when we were young so
what happened is that one day I went to
a conference and I met Adam steltzner
who was the person who put curiosity on
Mars and we had a chance to talk a
little bit and he agreed to come and
talk in our department of genetics
because we knew that eventually the
effort to go into space was going to
intersect with with our info with the
genetic information genetic technologies
so my department actually was shocked
that he would come and talk with us and
people were saying why is he coming to
talk to us and then it dawned on
everyone because we are actually moving
together to try and figure out a way to
protect astronauts in space and to think
about 500 or 5,000 years into the future
and what happened is that turned into
one of the most exciting and successful
symposiums we had in our department with
graduate students and postdocs leading
that and the faculty then following the
Graduate Institute graduate students and
postdocs started thinking more
creatively about the work that they were
doing in their labs and how that work
might apply to space and that is how the
consortium got together
sort of a an excitement brought by
realization can you give us an example
of two of what of how this alters your
thinking about genetics it became well
genetics is moving very much into the
realm of application and invention of
technologies that didn't exist and in
fact possibly genomes that did not exist
so much of the department focuses on
disease the detection of disease and
therefore information of personal
genetics can help astronauts determine
what their predispositions might be if
they're going to go on a long long trip
in space we also do a lot of work on
understanding DNA damage and how to
repair DNA damage there's work on
longevity how to extend lifespan and
also I work particularly on protection
against radiation and then so those are
all the things that are happening and
the goal in mind is to protect
astronauts on space but also take what
we learn in space to take care of humans
on earth what about zero gravity what
about low gravity microgravity how is
that I mean we know it has physiological
effects we could talk about those you we
will talk about those when we get to the
twins a little bit later I guess but but
is there any effective gravity on the
genome directly on the genome on gene
regulation on gene expression on any of
those sorts of things either of you I'd
say you know very much so as soon as you
get into space we see thousands of genes
changing their expression what we've
seen in analyzing the data from the last
couple years of the study is that some
of these genes immediately revert back
to their normal state when you return
back to earth but there are still
hundreds that stay perturb that I've
lost whatever was regulating them you
know essentially back to the normal
state so we can see this is the short
list of the risk genes that or the space
change that we're going to keep an eye
on for the next well for every astronaut
that goes up probably or these genes
here that we know what their role is
their function is or these just I mean
these are just this is just looking at
your the genes on earth here the genes
there and the ones that change out a lot
of them are some of the stress response
genes DNA damage repair gene so there is
definitely a physiological and genetic
response to space travel and that there
is a
a stress response to a large degree but
one of the more surprising things we saw
so far is that the telomeres actually
got longer in space and so we often
think of our genome being good for the
Fountain of Youth
there you go up to the space and
technically you're going closer to the
speed of light so you're a little bit
younger than everyone on earth so you
can be a little bit taller so you can be
younger taller lose weight and be
younger I'm going to sign but there's
increased radiation your body puffs up
you have to eat you there's no shower
and you generally exchange all your
microbes with everyone in a small
aluminum can basically so there's the
cons I guess I see so there are some
interesting genetic responses that we we
knew we'd see gene expression changes
because those change every time you eat
every time you sleep is associating
rhythm or even epigenetic changes or how
DNA is packaged we know we expected that
but I was gonna ask you actually about
circadian rhythms in space what I mean
it's a kind of an Earthbound ideas yeah
well every 90 minutes essentially have a
new sunrise and there's really
interesting things that we can also see
in the data is when they go to sleep
there there's there's no up there's no
down so they'll just kind of go in a
closet and close the door just so that
it's dark they get some semblance of
circadian rhythm but the other
interesting thing is when you sleep
normally there's enough currents in the
air because we're all terrestrial beings
that you get enough oxygen flowing by
you and the air moves but if in space
actually you'll end up sleeping in a
cloud of carbon dioxide so actually we
can see even there when they wake up in
the morning essentially they've been you
know sleeping in their own basically gas
exchange excrement and then you can see
it in the physiological responses that
they're slightly suffocating during the
night so there's actually a race to see
who can get the best you know fan action
in the space station to avoid that it's
that hard to put fans in the space
station well they're loud some of it's
the noise but you get used to it after a
while I think Caleb your physicist is
there is there a solution to like maybe
we should make more gravity are there
ways of producing at least minimal
gravity environments well you know in a
in a space station spacecraft you can
always do things like spin it up
so this is something that I mean if
anyone's ever seen 2001 right you
remember famous scenes where he's
jogging around this great ring that
encircles the spacecraft the ring is
spinning and that that centripetal force
can be used to mimic the acceleration
that you feel here on the earth or some
fraction of it and I guess I'm not sure
it's ever been actually deployed in
space it gets kind of tricky though
because unless you build a really
enormous spinning spacecraft mere
hundreds of meters across
you can certainly spin something
something smaller but you have things
like the Coriolis effect to worry about
so if you reach across to grab something
your where your hand is is now in a
different moving frame the rest of you
is or you throw something to your
colleague across the room it'll kind of
go around the corner so you know it
introduces other complexities to living
in space but my understanding is and I
don't know if this is really true
because it's it's not a perfect mimicry
of gravity that you can certainly create
a form of artificial gravity by spinning
up the environment and living on the
inside of a spinning ring and that may
help mitigate some of these so the space
station and that's sort of one thing
where there's really virtually I guess
zero gravity but if you were to be on
Mars you're not in zero gravity anymore
there's less gravity than here but
there's gravity does it make a
difference or it's still a prominent are
we that finely tuned to a gravitational
pull that that even a small difference
makes a difference I think you I don't
know if we know X I mean you know yeah
the moon is like one-sixth the gravity
and like people that were there were
only there a couple days but but the
body's quite adaptive you can see I mean
on the way we saw but now on the space
station is just with bungee cords and
there's a guy who I met at the human
research program meeting and he's you
know you meet people and he says well
I'm the guy who designed the treadmill
in the space station I was like oh
that's great it's really cool to meet
that guy who did that and you know it's
obviously it's a really cool device but
with a limited market in terms of sales
but it was
amazing device and they bits a bunch of
bungee cords a treadmill that's really
rigorously designed but that is the
closes they can get to simulating
gravity and in the metabolomic data
what's such the president in the
bloodstream you can see both the markers
for bone density loss actually the the
physical loss and calcium shows up in
the urine as well as all the enzymes
activating for bone deposition which
essentially really activate every time
you have something like gravity and so
it's an ongoing battle on the space
station for the astronauts today just to
maintain what they have but it's hard
and I think if you're on Mars
I think the first generation of people
there would adapt to some degree I think
the big interesting question would be
what happens in f1 the other second
third fourth generation and that you
know there's been a lot of science
fiction written about how the people be
taller and misshapen and look like me in
the morning kind of thing it's you know
what they look like
so there's several whips so I guess we
could get into that a little bit now I
was gonna save that for later but since
we're here we might talk about that so
that would be sort of an epigenetic
epigenetic effect right that that by a
second or third generation you begin to
see alterations and at least gene
expression if not mutations and genes
themselves as a result of some of these
environmental effects is that kind of
the idea that we're talking about there
right we're we're actually moving into
the realm of Lamarque where you a
lineage will pick up do we come back
eventually and actually I think the mark
is coming back because this is a
proposal that an individual organism
because of environmental stresses or
experiences will experience some stress
and then it's progeny will actually
inherit the response let's say that the
parent had and that was looked down upon
for a very long time however I can tell
you I was at a meeting recently and
finally someone yelled up from the
audience that said just say the l word
and the speaker said okay I'm talking
about Lamarck and there is evidence now
from many areas to say that an
individual organism may be able to pick
up a response or a trait that will
appear in the project
in an altered form or a slightly
modified form and then will be horrible
right in some cases its heritable for
three to four or five generations and
then the absence of the stimulus will
disappear in other cases I guess people
think that it can be more permanent
we've seen that multiple generations if
you have viruses that will infect some
of the warm c elegans there's a model
organism a small nematode for about two
to three generations they still maintain
some of the defensive micro rna's but
then they'll slowly fade away so even we
think of DNA being you know here you
know epigenetic changes being heritable
but there's even some evidence that a
memory of the RNA responds to a viral
infection is heritable as a paper from
oh did Rajavi three years ago that
showed this and so it's interesting
there definitely is a cellular memory
that is present what often we just call
imprinting but it seems to be more more
complex and more pervasive than
originally thought question yes I
allowed just a rest
so thinking about let's say going to
Mars people going to Mars and living on
Mars and one of the things that
interests me I'd know nothing about it
but it seems like an important factor
apart from their internal microbiome is
the environmental microbiome and I
assume that Mars is abiotic at the
moment but it's truly sterile then I
guess there's two questions should we be
bringing along and environmental
microbiome to live in but if we bring it
from the earth and we dump it on Mars
which has less gravity a different
radiation environment is it going to go
through its own epigenetic change not be
the thing we want to be surrounded by I
mean I know it's very hard to predict
but well we know bacteria neighs become
more violent and have more resistance to
antibiotics that's been published by
multiple groups there's even an analogue
even in hospitals if you look at where
the most and antimicrobial resistance
markers are the antibiotic resistance
it's actually present more on the
surfaces and it is of the patients from
a paper just published two weeks ago
writ large the idea that being there
under such strong selection pressure you
might be enriching for the organisms
that might be the most resistant
effectively on these surfaces and so
it's been one study but it had 1500
samples so it's really intriguing
thoughts up to your point of you send
them you know you send when we send
people anywhere that you're sending an
ecosystem not just a person as well as
what their environment and they'll be
under a lot of more intense and faster
selection pressure as soon as they get
to Mars so I think we will have to have
you know rapid Diagnostics you can't
send a sample back to earth to see what
what the bacteria is you'll have to
sequence it there on Mars and one of the
things we worked on with a team at now
so it's just to do the first DNA
sequencing in space and so we it's not
possible to actually do Diagnostics of
what it is it so you had to pick from
one of ten antibiotics you might be able
to know right away which one to pick
instead of guessing si I heard that nASA
has a very very stringent sterilization
process for all the equipment that
actually is one of the difficulties for
designing equipment and that also many
years ago a group of individuals or
nations got together to designate
certain planets or certain I guess they
banned the contamination of planets what
is and I think that's being reassessed
what's the status the planetary
protection basically it's an
organization within NASA as well as an
agreement between ESA and Jackson and
NASA is to as the name in sound zyou
want to protect other planets from us
vermin and filth thus that will go out
and distribute our filth the but really
they are obviously for discovery
purposes they're they're relatively
pristine environments and you don't want
to have discovered alien life but just
to have discovered what you brought with
actually just had a long you know
exchanged yesterday with a guy who
sequence two organism that would
cultured from the space station he
thinks it's alien because it had evolved
to be different enough from what's on
earth and we're debating about whether
that's true that's a strain of bacillus
and they're funky to begin with but you
know the idea is that we I think it's
interesting for two reasons one is that
it's probably already failed if you
sequence the DNA in clean rooms these
are other samples we're getting in two
weeks from now there's always there's
DNA everywhere it's really it's
literally impossible to get rid of the
most abundant biomolecule on this plan
you know the DNA is everywhere if you
look at where it's coming from and maybe
cellulose is the most abundant but in
terms of a information content molecule
it's everywhere it's in the air it's in
the atmosphere it's deep underground
it's in hydrothermal vents you know
there are bacteria they've had billions
of years of a head start so they're
they're everywhere and we've seen if you
take the the blank samples from the
cleanroom they're they're not actually
always clean so on the one hand we think
maybe we've already failed or succeeded
depending on your perspective but the
other thing is I think eventually if you
think long long long term this idea of
planetary protection is fallacious from
its first foundation you actually if you
think long enough ahead that say three
four billion years eventually the Sun
will engulf the inner planets and so
let's say we've done a perfect job and
we have wonderful world peace on earth
and it's kumbaya every night and there's
no famine and there's no disease there's
no war it's wonderful but if we're all
still here on earth we will all die and
if we're still here in three billion
years so again it's always off but it
doesn't matter if you've protected all
the planets they will all be engulfed by
you know the Sun so if you really want
to think about long-term preservation of
our species there as well as all those
which were responsible for it at some
point you'll have to go to another
planet and therefore you know in lay
down the microbes that were never from
there so the autochthonous state we live
in here on this planet will have to
eventually go to others or if we don't
it'll all go away except for what we've
broadcast in this space so I think it's
um it's a nice idea that eventually
we'll have to fail so far most of all we
talked about is sort of haphazard in the
evolutionary sense of haphazard that is
these things go out there they'll
survive or they won't survive they'll
undergo natural selection may be some
sort of epigenetic modification if
they're lucky to get to through a couple
of generations but what about the
possibility of actually designing things
to go out there which we can do now even
to ourselves with techniques like CRISPR
cast nine gene Drive maybe you could
explain a little bit of that for us and
whether or not this is the kind of thing
we should be thinking about and doing I
definitely think this is something we
should think about not just for space
application button course on the planet
so people have been modifying genomes
for a long long time
we have quite a wide variety of ways of
doing it but there are a couple things
that made it not reasonable to think
about modifying in any practical way and
one is the targeting and the other is
the efficiency those are the two things
that are getting you mean targeting you
want to modify this part of a chromosome
you want to just modify that and you
want to do it efficiently and until
recently we did not have the machinery
the enzymatic machinery to do that and
then just a few years ago 2013 through
this technique this molecule or this
mechanism called CRISPR we now have the
efficiency and much much better
targeting as well as two other very good
technologies for modifying genomes zinc
fingers and talons
so this triumvirate of machineries
really give us tremendous potential to
modify genomes and I think probably many
of you have been involved or read
articles have been involved in
conversations having to do with just how
much do we want to apply this I would
say it's really almost as if our species
has moved has moved into a new era we
passed a milestone where we can now
intellectually understand ourselves
before even an individual is born and
have a better understanding not perfect
understanding and now we have the
capacity to design so then the
responsibility that comes with it and
the responsibility to write and it
brings up the issue of judgment we now
can think about genomes and and judge
them based on all different kinds of
measuring sticks and this is what I
think the world is thinking very hard
about we need to involve all different
communities in this I'd like to talk
about the twins experiment now in space
so let's back into space a little bit
would you were very involved in so maybe
you could tell us a little bit about
what mark and Scott Kevin Kelly Morgan
Scott Kelly
so those not familiar with the study it
was a plan - it was really a unique
opportunity because we had twin brothers
both of whom are actually astronauts and
so could you imagine being I don't have
a in the room our pair
but could you imagine being printed I go
both my sons are astronauts pupae to
party be like yeah whatever it's not
only true I've know really both my sons
my twins and they're both astronauts
astronaut G we've confirmed that they're
twins with the genome sequencing I can
say that for sure that's definitely
confirmed the the plan was it was
actually launched at a press conference
because Scott Kelly was going up for the
longest American mission in space which
is a full year and and when they were
planning the mission oh yeah I can see
then that there as they were planning
out the mission they said you know
actually one of the reporters who said
well you have a twin on earth you guys
doing anything with the twin and they
said well we don't everything it means
the plan but I meet as soon as the press
conference finish so here's a big high
five to the press to ask good questions
is they said well maybe we should do
something so they've actually the twins
themselves really proposed it to NASA
and said we should do something so they
had an announcement to have people
submit applications and I had actually
sent an application to do astronaut
genomes back in and 2010 when I had just
started my laboratory actually wrote
this really interesting grant I said I
don't want any money from you I just
want DNA and they hadn't yet been
banking DNA from astronauts there's
number when you start a lab to give you
some funds to get started so it was a
peculiar grant but they said well we
don't actually don't have anything Bank
yet but then eventually when I knew they
made the announcement so great I've got
most of it written and submitted was one
of the labs selected before they said
okay we have identical twins and we're
gonna monitor them everything we
possibly can because the big question
was well what changes in the body when
you're in space and so I said well well
no one's ever looked so we don't know so
we should look at everything we possibly
can to understand the physiological
changes to the body so we're looking at
the DNA what changes of genetically
epigenetically we talked about the
modifications of DNA what happens to
your RNA molecules or your transcriptome
as well as the modifications to RNA
which we talked about protein changes
metabolites how DNA is wrapped in in
package and all your cells microbes on
the stomach and the skin in the mouth
and also in the environment looking also
at what are called metabolomics or small
molecules in your blood cognition how
fast actually they can do tasks they're
also looking at vasculature and during
full-body MRIs and doing all these tests
we get over 19 time points so the the
amazing thing about the study was not
only it felt like a Michael Crichton
novel it
like some like repentance books where
they I get a peculiar mix of scientist
like we need a mathematician and we need
a geneticist so we need a physicist to
go to Jurassic Park you know is like a
weird mixture of people and their - we
have a telomere biologists some
geneticists and proteomics experts a guy
who spends all day designing you know
computer games for cognition testing
cardiologists you know it's really it's
a it's a team effort and you know just
one of the team but it's also forced us
to think about systems biology so if we
want to measure all of these changes and
then integrate them there actually is
not really an infrastructure that exists
either for medical records at hospitals
or for astronaut monitoring to integrate
all that information so it's been a
computational exciting challenge you
talked about challenges before it's
great because it's the most challenging
integration problem that we have but
then also some of the biologies been
really interesting we've actually seen
already that your telomeres get longer
in space the stress response genes
really activate the microbiome inside
your gut changes that but that wasn't
too surprising they're also eating
different food and we can also see you
know some of the responses to the
hypoxia you know the changes in whether
you have it changes in oxygen and carbon
was the earthbound brother on the same
diet and all the rest of that we tried
to get mark to have the same diet and in
he play lead refuser actually not
politely and definitively and said you
can go you know you can imagine the rest
of that sentence but we did get them to
both keep food logs and his log though
was more you know so Scott's up in space
is highly regulated food it's it's
rehiring rehydrated and then heated
there's a little bit of exchange with
the Russian side so they do exchange
some food and other odd things we keep
track of so the Russian water supply is
different from the American and European
the Russians put a little bit of copper
into their water supply whereas the
Americans don't but they both try and
get rid of microbial contaminants so we
have to track that as well and but but
Mark's food log was more you know
burritos and margaritas it was very
little very a very terrestrial space at
all you can't get a care package there
any benefits to being in space anything
good come of it for your genome your bio
or anything
this is an ongoing debate amongst all
the twins investigators because we keep
getting this question because all we
keep talking about is you know permanent
changes to your microbiome epigenetic
change is the only potentially you know
benefit might be is the telomere
lengthening and actually they come back
in pretty good shape butts because they
they have to exercise every single
morning for at least 30 to 45 minutes
just to maintain their bone density and
so it really is no again margarita so we
do often joke incorrectly that this is
the worst powered study in human history
as an N of to do in n of one because it
and so we you know we the study was was
never designed and never could be the
definitive measure of what happens in
the body in space you know writ large
but it is the first time nASA has gotten
into genomics it's the first time they
really want to think about precision
medicine for astronauts which they have
a nice poster now that models all this
and they they want to begin to look at
the question of well if we have a genome
could we think about who's at higher
risk for hypoxia related genes or those
people that might respond better or
worse to different pharmacological
treatments in space so they they are
doing very much what our our health care
system is in having a genome guided view
of medicine your genome and your
microbial so would that ever reflect
back on who could be an astronaut and
who couldn't do you think this is an
ongoing point of contention within NASA
so they the IRB that we got for the twin
study itself to do documentary for human
experiments
were you doing experiments on humans you
need to have a board to go through and
make sure you're not doing evil things
to them as you can imagine and there's
unfortunate history in genetics and
eugenics for really bad things we're
done without institutional review boards
to make sure you're informing the
patients of their risks and making sure
that you're all the experiments are
medically necessary and that you have
good controls so we this is the first
time it's been done for NASA and they we
want to use this for a subsequent
astronauts but they it's they don't the
flight surgeons and the astronauts have
a kind of a love-hate relationship more
kind of hate hate is that they the
flight surgeons are always looking for
some
- potentially you know maybe that's a
high risk and but if they flag something
has to be enough of a risk that they'll
keep someone from going on the mission
and all the astronauts have trained for
years some cases decades and it's their
life's dream to go to space and so they
they will do things that you would
imagine humans would do is the dis
ometer which tells you how much
radiation you've had they'll hide it in
the space station so they can go back up
for different missions but keep it in a
protected part of the space station or
they will they they want to go back up I
mean they they it's their dream right so
if you want to space addiction so
there's a big debate in NASA how much
can we really reliably tell someone
about whether they should or should not
go to space just based on their genome
and most of the consensus is we're not
there yet that we could say but but it's
a question of I think when not if and
it's not it's like a little bit like the
movie Gattaca what most people in this
room is probably seen but it hopefully
not the bad version of that hoping it
would be all the information that you
could do to protect yourself and for
example from your genome you can tell
what drugs you should or should not take
that you would respond well to or not or
where your microbial genome so hopefully
we'd use the good of genomes to to
reinforce good genetic circuits as well
as even protect them was the hope I
think the situation is made more put in
stark a relief because the trips that
people are anticipating now are longer
and so if you're going to be taking a
10-year journey then you can actually
for some cancers calculate a
predisposition or a chance that you are
going to develop a cancer in a very long
period of time and you will be too far
away to come back for treatment and I
think that's where the discussion of
genetics personal genetics has become a
little more interesting and and there
you have to you have to take it into
consideration it would be foolish not to
so you know it's a big if if all the
evidence is solid and grounded and
replicated and really informative then
it should be used but it's it's getting
all the scientists and the flight
surgeons at the point where they all
feel comfortable making that decision
but I think you when you think of
missions to Mars or longer missions
you know you can't get back fast
oh no well I yeah I mean this is very
interesting and I was thinking about
Mars specifically because you know
really the only way to learn the
peculiarities of the Martian environment
and its impact on humans is going to be
to send that first batch of ideally many
practical twins to do that experiment
because it will be it will be a very
different experience in low-earth orbit
the radiation environment on route for
let's say six months will be different
and the stresses of that will be
different and then experience on the
surface which no human has yet set foot
on Mars so we don't have the slightest
idea it's a different chemical
environment that you're going to have a
hard time keeping out of your you know
out of your potato chips if you stray
outside of the habitat and it's in the
Martian so that that's interesting I
mean it almost is it sounds like you
would have to have a a biological
expedition would be one of the first
things to do do you think that it would
be a good intermediate step to not to
focus of course to try and get on the
planet certain live on a separate planet
but to actually create a space station
that will where we would be able to
control the environment better rather
than focus entirely on trying to get on
a planet or alter the planet alter
ourselves to live on that planet your
knowledge of the of the universe what do
you think is that's an interesting
question I mean I I suspect from the
practical point of view from a rocket
science point of view it may be equally
challenging to construct let's say a
more elaborate Space Station that would
say mimics Martian gravity for example
because that's something you would want
to do for it to be worthwhile also if it
didn't low-earth all
you will not be exposed to the same
radiation environment so you're really
talking about I think I mean I it sounds
like a reasonable idea to me but it
would be a a structure a space station
that would have to be maybe it would be
orbiting the moon or something like that
at all to it you know to get a little
bit closer to what you need for that
experiment more that rather than trying
to find a planet where we could thrive
in our make it like our environment just
to perhaps forgo that until we find a
planet that it's perfect for us and
instead work on building a station that
is just like earth I mean unfortunately
you know if there are planets perfect
for us they're a long way away around
other stars so then we're into the whole
realm of interstellar exploration and
you know well this is something that's
in the circles back to my first comments
about you know we have this pitcher
Hollywood is partly to blame and also
wishful thinking over the years of you
know going to Mars Mars is the Mars is
the other habitable planet and of course
it's it's an appalling place there's no
atmosphere it has less gravity it's got
nasty surface chemistry it has less
shielding against ultraviolet radiation
and cosmic radiation you know and it
makes me think back to I mean there's
this is a little anecdote about how we
get so fixated on certain ideas going
back to the very first robotic
spacecraft to go past Mars and I think
the late 1960s like what Mariner 4 I
think was the first flyby or fit and
then there was Mariner 7 or 9 was an
orbiter the first u.s. orbiter to get to
Mars you can actually go and look at the
original scientific literature and
people like Carl Sagan who was active at
that point was literally writing papers
speculating that well when we get to
Mars and start taking the
high-resolution images we may see this
pattern of vegetation or this vegetation
there might be certain types of
herbivores and so on and of course well
two things happen first
they get to Mars and Mars is encased in
one of its global dust storms and so all
that could be seen the first close-up
high-res orbital images of Mars were the
peaks of olympus mons and a couple of
the other Tharsis volcanoes and the rest
of the planet was covered in dust so
they actually had to wait a couple of
months I mean it must have been really I
mean it's kind of a science fictiony
thing and waiting for the clouds to
clear or the dust storms to clear to
reveal more dust a terrible planet came
from well yeah you know time II I'm sure
people I'm sure people speculated so
that's just my way of saying that yeah
we so we in our own solar system had
many pipes so coming back to what you
said I agree
I mean it's so the the engineering
challenges are different to some
advantages of building a a raw space
habitat for yourself is you don't have
to lift it in and out of a gravity field
all the time getting stuff down onto
Mars is a complete nightmare because you
don't have much of an atmosphere to
break yourself actually and this is why
the last big Rover couldn't use airbags
to bounce on surfaces and do the final
slow down it had to use some kind of
rocket crane system because there isn't
enough atmosphere there's enough gravity
to get you to the surface hard but there
isn't enough atmosphere to use as a
natural break but you know what's
interesting to me the idea of a fully
contained
Space Station is do we know how to do
that for the long term I mean the ISS it
gets resupplied you know you can can
flush out things every so often I assume
you can sometimes when you see a
shooting star at night it's not a
shooting star can you tell if it's
Russian or though
different emission spectra you can see
the color I think it's I think it is a
very very interesting question but it is
an immense challenge and I you know if
you actually add up the total mass that
humans have elevated from the surface of
the earth and put into space it's not
very much I mean it's I did this
calculation at some point and I think
it's it's some tiny fraction of the mass
of an oil tanker has actually been
lofted into space even though there are
thousands of pieces of satellite and
junk floating around it's really
expensive you know about 460 seven
people or 472 have left earth and then
come back there's not that many people
you don't have really experienced it but
but it's a good good question you know
maybe the self-contained environments
are waiting till we find the right place
but even if it is the right place you'd
have to send people there they a lot of
them would probably not make it and I
think our intuitions about this way
everyone wants to go there and have it
be one you know kumbaya and be fine but
the problem you think of like the people
who first came to Plymouth Rock in the
first winter more than 90 percent of
them died that winter but more came the
next year and so I think the the
entrepreneurial and or pioneering kind
of spirit may require or historically
has required a lot of sacrifice and you
know there's a contrast when they came
to Plymouth Rock there was an atmosphere
here there was water it was a little
easier but they're there they're very I
mean I think NASA has you know a lot of
really great homages to the astronauts
they've lost over the years and but they
all recognize it's a really high-risk
job and I think it'll be true whenever
and however we send people another
possibility and this is something I
think I've even written briefly about
you know there are places on earth you
could begin to test some of the two and
it's not just the desert somewhere but
yeah set up your colony on Everest you
know at the top of Everest right where
people usually die just right because
there isn't enough oxygen to sustain you
for any great length of
time there's a lot more UV radiation you
know there are no natural reefs or
Tomatoes right yeah so there's some
interesting perhaps interesting
experiments that could be done here on
earth not just building a pretend Mars
habitat you know Iceland or something
which is interesting from for testing
the psychological aspects of isolation
and salt but we could do a little bit
better here on earth NASA about the
immediate problems bone loss muscle loss
kidney stones visual problems blood
pressure problems and but for many it
might be you might this might be more
encouraging for you waiting they said
these problems are very complicated for
the first few days of first few weeks
but then interestingly the human body
acclimates and they say even bone loss
and muscle loss is appropriate for space
where things weigh less and where the
fact they say you get calluses on the
top of your feet because you're using
the top of your feet to hold you in
place you lose the calluses on the
bottom and they say after a while the
human body acclimates for a long term
and the problem is when they come back
to earth so these habitats that we build
and these things that we think are
terrible for our body in the long run he
was saying actually the body may be
adjusting just the way it needs to
adjust in the long term even Scott when
he came back to earth he one of the
hardest things that had happened him his
first day back was that his the weight
of clothes made his skin hurt and so he
because he hadn't felt the weight of
just closed so he had the notoriously
spent some of the time just wandering
around the house native and and just to
just think it was T was painful to wear
clothes which how does brother feel
about it but they weren't sky being a
FaceTime
so the trick is to send people out there
or not let them come back okay with that
let's let's take some questions this is
a salon so we'd like to hear from you
guys as well that's okay good so we have
some questions yes give him a try
before he blasts off so hi I'm me Shawn
and my question is so you talked in the
beginning a lot about like biology and
how human genes could make him as adapt
but like if someone went to Mars right
and they were like having a baby
wouldn't the baby would develop
differently in the fetus they would have
maybe weaker bones and less muscle mass
and stuff like that and what what would
you think they'd be able to return back
to earth with the weaker bone mass and
the weaker muscle mass and the like
never being experienced the high gravity
and high atmospheric pressure of Earth
great question the answer is it would
definitely hurt when they came came back
here I think it wouldn't necessarily
less it was thousands and thousands of
years that could eventually become
literally a different species but quite
quite possibly were they if they were to
come here would be to pain for they
would then need spacesuits to come to
earth and they would be just as been our
cousins so you you could very well
imagine that with enough time they will
become a different species so I I think
that it's actually Nevitt of all I mean
even if just people go people living in
the South versus and Northeast have
different accents and you know that
didn't take that long really but so the
yeah it'll start with language it'll
start with culture I'll start with the
into nations and very quickly it
manifests in the biology and the
selection pressure will be so fast and
so strong I think it'll be it'll be an
extraordinary evolutionary experiment on
our on our own species but it will be I
think there'll be changes I raises a
certain irony these ideas for example
Elon Musk talking about you know
colonizing Mars is the back-up plan
except they won't be human after a while
so it's not quite the back
plan you had in mind anyone to get there
NASA wants to be there by 2033 or 2035
and he wants to beat them and so there's
a bit of a battle dependent but but it
should be soon actually you would be
about the right age to actually be one
of the first people to go to Mars one
way rocket a one-way rocket it's so hard
to visualize the future it's so far away
and there are tons of problems that come
up immediately and I was you know what
I'm kind of concerned that there's a
lack of discussion about it because
obviously everybody has different
experiences and views on ethics and
stuff and I was wondering what kind of
people you think should be in charge of
dictating the ethics of genetics and
balancing future thinking with
present-day problems that is such a
timely perfect question I think that
geneticists realized we have as I
mentioned before moved into a new era we
have the capacity to really change the
way genetics enters our lives and how it
affects our lives I think we all
recognize also that we are in service to
the world it's not it's less and less
what we think is fun to do when I was a
student it was how to figure out how
things worked I know how did this happen
how did how did this evolve very much
now it's turned into we know enough of
how this works that we have the capacity
to invent something we know enough about
the basis of this disease and the
location of this disease that then we
can think about changing it and that so
we're no longer in solidly in the
discovery mode we're in the mode of
altering our environment you are our
environment we're all part of the
environment so I think you will find
greater greater agreement among
scientists that this is a world problem
and it's gonna have to saw by world
discussion are there's certain people
that will be chosen
I certainly hope not I think and the
more
noise people make the more opinions you
voice the less chance it's going to be
made by a small group of people I don't
think we want to make it with a small
group of people of it rests really on
how much involvement all of you take on
tears unto yourselves oh definitely it
is so far thing and should be a
community effort like the scientists
talking with everyone in the community
you know religious scholars to to people
working in every different discipline
and one interesting thing is I think it
should not be just left up to the
scientists themselves actually at the
meeting we were recently at the genome
project right meeting there was a survey
during the meeting of one of the
questions was do you think Sciences are
doing enough to mitigate potential risks
and think about the ethics of the
problem of engineering genomes and 70%
of the people at the meeting said yeah I
think so I said well that right there
I've tweeted that and so this is a
reason why we shouldn't just depend on
the scientist because it's too easy to
fall in love with the data and to see
the awesome power and potential of the
biology and the tweaking of it to
improve life and eradicate disease you
you can easily get caught up in thinking
oh this is great yes we're thinking
about it we have panels but you know I
think it's not going to be enough and
most of people at the meeting while
optimistic very much welcomed feedback
comments they want ever they want
everyone to be involved if and if they
don't then they're working with dr. evil
welcomed the idea in many ways that that
will once again begin listening to
philosophers and historians and science
and not just technicians as it were so I
think that's actually a I see this
optimistically I would say if we get
that back in the mix questions more
question if we're the species gonna
continue we are going to be thinking
about millions even billions of years
into the future so and there will become
point where even Mars is not a habitable
place for us so expanding on to outer
reaches of the solar system and beyond
and that the farther we get apart
species of humans will become isolated
and possibly speciate but the universe
if you keep going eventually that's
where you end up for sure but more the
idea in that we will at some point
hopefully be expanding outside of our
solar system beyond the influences of
the dangers of radiation from our own
Sun and my question was what influences
are humans gonna have in deep space on
like our physiology and living beyond
you know the influence of our own Sun
the radiation environment of our Sun is
certainly an issue but there's plenty of
so-called cosmic radiation that comes
from other sources throughout our galaxy
comes from other stars it comes from
black holes consuming that here it comes
of neutron stars it comes from particles
accelerated in galactic magnetic fields
we have a bit of an idea of what that
environment is like it's pretty similar
to sort of deep interplanetary
environment in our own solar system so
it's it's kind of nasty it's probably
not any safer and yeah and also just to
add to that I mean let's if we're just
thinking about it with the element of
realism to get to another star in a
reasonable amount of time now we may
have to engineer humans to live longer
to do this efficiently but you will have
to move fast moving fast through
interstellar space brings all sorts of
hazards that are quite mechanical I mean
the you know you may spend most of your
time patching up your colony ship
because a microscopic piece of
interstellar dust - zipped through and
you know went through dudes cocktail but
I think it's there I mean the radiation
environment I think is is pretty similar
to deep into planetary space I know
geneticists are trying to identify the
genes involved in DNA repair but we also
are looking for ways in which the genome
which
plays a big part in our life can
withstand onslaught my life in
particular is interested in some very
mysterious sequences and all of us
people don't know what they do they're
the least evolving sequences known by
definition they've been in all of us for
three to five hundred million years
without change essentially without
change and their big surprise for
genomicist they do not disturb I do not
disturb ever but recently some of our
work has shown that I suggested that
they are like we call them genomic
Canaries they're scattered all over your
genome and what we think they do it's a
model and when they detect a damaging
break in the chromosome they get rid of
the cell that has that break so I think
it's possible as we explore our genome
more and more work and we'll find the
tools to be able to fashion ourselves to
withstand radiation damage
perhaps some we're also studying in the
lab desiccation there ourselves that you
can desiccate down to nothing you can
modify human cells and some insect cells
on their own you can modify it you can
try them it's kind of fun working this
field when someone sends you cells
normally they have to pack it in dry ice
they send it to you you pick it up at
FedEx you put in the freezer these cells
you send in an envelope you just pop it
in the envelope and send it through the
mail you keep these cells in your drawer
because they're dry nothing's gonna
happen to them you add water and they
grow so I think we're trying to fashion
tools that may be useful for long-term
travel in space other people are trying
to come up with ways in which lifespan
can be extended tremendously whether
these be new species potential
potentially but I think our mind is so
creative I think so far as you said the
extremes that we see within our own
solar system if we can conquer those
it's possible we can conquer many other
and the famous mathematical evolutionary
biologist named JB
[ __ ] Dane was English who was once
famously said not only is the universe
stranger than we imagined is stranger
than we can imagine
and that's often been seen to be some
sort of a limit on our cognitive
abilities can we really but the
interesting thing is he said that I
think in 1927 or 29 and since then we've
actually imagined some pretty strange
and rap that you never would have
imagined we could have imagined so so
that prediction has not actually come
true and I find that very positive and a
thing that people thought when you're on
those long missions people thought you
would just be at the whim of the
universe and have to just be subjugated
to this damage but with crisper and and
genome repair systems you could much
like you're continually repairing your
ship be constantly repairing your DNA on
the way and you would actually I think
if we'd have to do that actually
and you if it's a long enough mission
you'd have to have multiple generations
that live and die on the same vessel
before they get to the planet which
sounds awful but if you have all of
Netflix for the whole mission a couple
of questions what is your confidence
that Mars will be colonized in your
lifetimes or in this boy's life time by
colonized you mean having children and
spending their whole lifetime there well
I'm pretty old I think it probably won't
be in in my lifetime I will be I'll be
really happy just if we get there and
and if we've and if my life's work is in
any way contributed to help that I think
possible I think the thing in his
lifetime it's it's possible there'd be
the very first real colonists there but
but it's a rough place as well as Weaver
yeah I mean I think I awfully difficult
to predict I mean you've got a pretty
well yeah yeah but you've got in this
case you've got to predict the nature of
human will and you know the reality of
chances are those those first colonists
they're never coming back I mean that's
certainly the LR must plan and it makes
a great deal of sense
awfully difficult to bring people back
again but I you know I think it's
conceivable let's say Tesla does really
well in the next year within the next 10
to 20 years there'll be an effort at
least there'll be some sort of attempt
at an outpost I don't know if it would
be considered a colony we're out of time
but let me yeah thank the panel Chris
ting and caliber which please join me in
thanking them for a great conversation
thank you very much
[Music]